i got a question up there right so do
you guys think that they
underplayed adam warlock at all
absolutely they did we got one scene of
adam warlock because they spent oh
here's they brought him to the stage
here's donald warlock my question is
where the adam warlock get the soul
stone yeah and he's got that [ __ ] in his
head
the infinity stones are gone as far as
i'm aware like they don't exist anymore
yeah that was weird i mean it's like oh
and here's the side thing it was out of
my luck and you're like the stones back
at the end of ending
yeah so yeah they put the songs back at
the end of the game but the idea is they
put them back
to where they were supposed to be
god this is why this is why time travel
is such a [ __ ] in the ass sometimes just
like to my knowledge the stones still
exist so he could have just gone to the
plane and the stones did not exist
anymore okay so here's the idea okay
here's the idea
of this here's the idea why this starts
come on you're gonna want to record this
this diagram
[Music]
so point a
point b
all right uh-huh now we will say
along this timeline
all right um we will say right here is
i don't know this is
what what what year was it when thanos
snapped everything out of existence
2013.
oh we'll pick a random day we'll say
2013 2013 okay this is when thanos snaps
all right
five years later
2018
avengers
time
travel
right the avengers point b is just
whatever in the hell all right avengers
we'll say this is like the present
phase five land yeah phase five land
yeah so the avengers travel back in time
now
this point at which they travel back in
time
is this range here
this is everything
between
was it 2012 to
was what was the earliest point they
traveled back in time
it was like the 70s wasn't it it was uh
20 stars dad yeah yeah yeah yeah so
we'll say 1970 we'll say around
1970 something to
2000 i don't know
2012.
right okay
so that's this gap right here
so
they travel back the avengers travel
back
to this time period
now they snatch up all the stones from
this time period
right
parenthetical gordon is literally for
you yes i am okay okay i'm also looking
something up on the side real quick okay
so the avengers travel all the way back
in time during this time period
right they snatch up all the infinity
stones
now the reason why this matters is
because right here i don't know where to
see this is not to scale
right
thanos
destroys
the stones
thanos destroys the stones during this
point right here yes we'll say it's 2013
running up to here
so the vendors travel back in time to
this time period they snatch up all the
infinity stones once they're done they
bring the infinity stones all the way
back to point b
right this present moment and this is
this analogy right we say in point b
avengers
beat
thanos
now the ancient one warned them during
this time period
that if they don't return the stones
right back to where they were supposed
to be
they'll [ __ ] up the timeline yeah
so
after beating thanos they go
back to this point in time where captain
america does anyway
puts the stones back to where they're
supposed to be yeah
in doing that
this timeline remains intact
right this whole timeline
stays intact
which means at this moment
the stones are dead yeah okay so i'm
going to say right now that i felt
really dumb because the moment i saw the
a and the b diagram like from a to b i
was like oh i remember how this works
now but also you've gotten started and i
can't break the pacing of this so i'm
just
okay but that's that's that's the point
right there not imagine there's probably
people on there that needed that knew
that explanation exactly that's all
that's the way that works so
keeping the timeline intact which
captain america did by taking the stones
back to where they were supposed to be
the infinity stones are destroyed which
means they're destroyed because they get
snapped they no they get yeah thanos
destroys the stones right yeah so um
so he's like i use the stones to destroy
the stones which means in this present
right here
right
it doesn't make any sense that adam
warlock would have the infinity stone
what if it's a synthetic stone
there's never been synthetic red stones
they look green to me
it was hard to do yeah it's really hard
to see i bet you it's not even a stone
in the first place yes it's probably
just some weird energy mcguffin
but it looks like an infinity stone like
a soul stone
i don't know if it is but it can be
because the infinity stones are gone or
either that or the infinity stone
somehow came back